meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
gibt gewisse videos über die darf man da
es gibt gewisse videos bei denen diese
haltung lustig und dann gibt es noch
diejenigen videos für die man wenn man
bei denen nachts in die hölle kommt
kennt jeder ich war auch schon parade
und genau um diese videos dreht sich das
heutige video ich habe mich mehr max und
gewisser hass bringen gewissermaßen auch
max gegen nicht denn wie schon jetzt
videos bei denen man nicht lachen da
weil sonst ist man oft schlechter mensch
wunder kommt offiziell in die hölle
da der titel ist nicht übertrieben und
falls ihr euch dann gefragt glaubt mir
es ist begründet bei diesen videos darf
man nicht lachen genau dass die
challenge wir sind ja nicht ein lustig
erwischt hatten es geht darum nicht zu
lachen weil man sonst direkt mitbewohner
von satan wird wird dass ihr euch nicht
wundert leute wir fangen bei absoluten
todes gesichter an damit man jede
bewegung sieht passen auch selbst
aufstellen die kommentare mit einer
gedacht hat das nicht zugibt also
auseinandersetzung streiten sich böse
wörter ich kann mich wenn ich das schon
lustig ich weiß nicht warum
naja der grande boucle himmel gucken
noch mal guckt noch häufig gehen darüber
auf dass abgemacht dieses bild joachim
mertes und der direktor ist einfach
länger man darf nicht mit dem polo
masters ich anlegen äußerte sache so das
hat so eine sache nicht über uns lustig
[Applaus]
danach muss man sich nicht schlimm wie
jetzt war schon besser als mit puppen
diese bombe hat sich bei ihrem verletzt
kommt man schon zumindest eine
funktionierende das okay ich ja als
opfer nicht so kommen solche geräusche
kann nicht machen und fuß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
darüber kann man auch lachen weil das
ist offensichtlich weitaus nicht werbung
erwärmt werden treppen er als letzte
mannschaft liebsten ein bisschen weil
der opa sicherlich auch gute eltern kind
erstickte geschlagen
ich denke mich schnell wieder gerade am
boden sehr schnell solidarisiert und
einfach hingelegt weil da wo ich jetzt
bin ich beim bowlen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
er wird von klaus sich dann bist du
sicher damit rechnen damit dass wir auch
nein das ist nicht dein gesicht das
macht sonst ein lustiger und probiert es
nur wenige schauen leute einfach so den
gesichtsausdrücke zwei autos
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt mal in die kommentare
reichen bei welcher stelle ihr lastet
seit erde das was wir heute wachsen in
der stadt und verlinkt und über meinem
gesicht seht ihr jetzt ein zufälliges
video von einem kanal vertreter der
anderen schaut weiter bis dahin macht's
gut und klar